♪ ♪
>> Sean: SO TONIGHT, ASK
YOURSELF, WHY IS JOE BIDEN NOT
STANDING UP TO OUR ADVERSARIES
AROUND THE GLOBE?
WHY IS HE EMBOLDENING AND
ENABLING THEM ALL ACROSS THE
GLOBE?
JOE IS REWARDING VLADIMIR PUTIN
WITH NORTH STREAM 2, THE
PIPELINE, GIVING PUTIN MORE
LEVERAGE OVER OUR ALLIES IN
WESTERN EUROPE.
RUSSIA DID PAY HIS SON A LOT OF
MONEY, JOE IS SILENT ON CHINA
THREATENING OUR MILITARY AND
CHINA THREATENING ANYONE WHO
STANDS IN THE WAY OF WHAT THEY
ARE CALLING THE REUNIFICATION OF
TAIWAN.
HUNTER MADE A LOT OF MONEY THERE
TOO.
JOE ISN'T STANDING UP TO THE
IRANIANS AS THEY ARE NOW
ENRICHING URANIUM ONCE AGAIN,
MAKING PROXY PAYMENTS TO
TERRORIST GROUPS CONTINUING TO
BE THE LARGEST STATE SPONSOR OF
TERROR, AND WHAT'S JOE'S ANSWER?
HE LIFTS SANCTIONS, FORCE,
FORCES SOUTH KOREA TO PAY THE
IRANIAN MULLAHS $7 BILLION TO
FREE A SOUTH KOREA FLAGSHIP
SEIZED BY IRAN.
AND NOW THERE'S THIS, BECAUSE
WE'RE LEARNING MORE TONIGHT
ABOUT HOW IN IRANIAN AMERICAN
JOURNALIST IN NEW YORK WHO HAS
BEEN COURAGEOUS AND STAUNCH IN
HER CRITICISM OF THE REGIME WAS
THE TARGET OF A KIDNAPPING PLOT,
FOUR IRANIAN OPERATIVES IN THIS
COUNTRY CHARGED WITH CONSPIRING
TO KIDNAP HER.
AND THAT A FIFTH PERSON HAS BEEN
ARRESTED FOR FINANCE THE
OPERATION ACCORDING TO THE
INDICTMENT.
THESE IRANIAN INTELLIGENCE
ASSETS TRIED TO SCHEME TO LURE
HER TO A FOREIGN COUNTRY, KIDNAP
HER, SHIPPER OFF TO IRAN.
SHE IS ALSO THE VICTIM OF
EXTENSIVE SURVEILLANCE AND
STOCKING, INCLUDING THEIR VIDEO
FEED FROM HER HOME, BUT TONIGHT
SHE IS SPEAKING OUT AND SHE IS
STANDING STRONG AND IS CALLING
ON A BIDEN A ADMINISTRATION TO
STAND UP TO THE MULLAHS IN IRAN
AND CALLING ON THE BIDEN A
ADMINISTRATION TO NOT SEEK A
DEAL THAT EMBOLDENS THE IRANIAN
REGIME.
HERE NOW, JOURNALIST, AUTHOR.
FIRST, YOU ARE VERY COURAGEOUS
AND WE WILL PRAY FOR YOUR SAFETY
AND I MEAN THAT, TELL US WHAT'S
GOING ON.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME.
I WANT TO ACTUALLY START FROM
WHAT I HAVE BEEN WITNESSING IN
THE STREETS TODAY.
TODAY I'VE BEEN GIVING INTERVIEW
TO FOX NEWS AND CNN AND THEN AS
SOON AS I WALKED OUT FROM THE
BUILDINGS, PEOPLE ARE JUST --
AMERICAN PEOPLE WERE REALLY KIND
WITH ME.
THEY RECOGNIZE MINISTRIES, THEY
HUG ME, SOME OF THEM SAYING
GOD BLESS YOU, SOME OF THEM
SAYING WE ARE GLAD THAT YOU'RE
SAFE.
IT BROUGHT TEARS TO MY EYES, BUT
THAT SHOWS AMERICA.
THEY CARE ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS.
THEY CARE ABOUT THEIR FELLOW
PEOPLE AND FOX NEWS AND CNN BOTH
ONE DAY SAW THAT I WAS UNDER
SURVEILLANCE -- I'M ACTUALLY NOT
FEELING SAFE, NOT FEELING GOOD.
BOTH WITH DIFFERENT VIEWS, THEY
BOTH CARED ABOUT THE STORY.
THIS IS WHAT I WANT FROM BIDEN'S
AT ADMINISTRATION, BECAUSE EIGHT
MONTHS AGO WHEN THE FBI CAME TO
MY HOUSE AND TOLD ME THAT I'M
NOT SAFE HERE IN AMERICA BECAUSE
THE [INDISCERNIBLE] HIRED A
PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR IN
NEW YORK -- ACTUALLY THEY ARE
TAKING PHOTOS OF MY PRIVATE
LIFE, PHOTOS OF MY STEPCHILDREN,
PHOTOS OF MY HUSBAND, PHOTOS OF
MYSELF IN MY GARDEN.
I WAS SHOCKED AND I COULDN'T
BELIEVE --
>> Sean: I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
TIME.
>> BUT I'M ASKING NOW BIDEN --
>> Sean: DO YOU FEEL SAFE NOW?
DO YOU FEEL SAFE NOW?
>> LOOK, I HAVE TO SAY THAT I AM
UNDER FBI'S PROTECTION, BUT AS
FAR AS THEY ARE IN POWER, NOT
ONLY ME, NO ONE IS SAFE.
NO ONE.
RIGHT NOW THAT I'M TALKING TO
YOU, U.S. CITIZENS ARE IN PRISON
JUST BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT TOOK
THEM HOSTAGE AND USING THEM LIKE
BARGAINING CHIPS, SO I WANT
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO BE
STRONG, TAKE AN ACTION.
BECAUSE THEY ARE ACTING LIKE
ISIS.
ISIS TOOK HOSTAGES, THEY BEHEAD
PEOPLE.
>> Sean: WE PRAY FOR YOUR
SAFETY AND YOUR FAMILY'S SAFETY
AND YOU ARE VERY BRA